Christmas is all about spending time
with family and exchanging gifts but it
doesn't hurt to have some tasty treats
while you do it Dana and the judge paid
a visit to Carlos Bakery home of the
Cake Boss
[Music]
all right here we are in Hoboken New
Jersey at Carlos bake shop and we are
going to do something pretty incredible
which is somehow they're going to teach
us how to bake a cake and she's not
competitive at all no no not at all but
we're gonna see who makes the better
cake
is that all the ingredients here what do
we do first so first thing we're going
to do is we got these are all the
ingredients so we got flour sugar eggs
we put custard in our cake that's what
makes it so moist
yeah that's the secret I think we should
put all the wet ingredients you guys
gotta do the work obviously we do wet
ingredients first put all the wet
ingredients
doing a good job over here too thanks
buddy she's doing all right yep okay now
we're gonna crank the bread you can push
this right back up
oh boy oh boy oh boy now what
I'll check it out Dana let's push this
down all right look at that that's good
judge no waste
okay all right that's it okay let's see
all right I'm gonna put it in the uh how
busy are you as a family business to get
everybody that their Thanksgiving from
Thanksgiving to Christmas we are all
here together 95. oh it's awesome
you know what I do merry Christmas
everybody Merry Christmas from paulos
for Christmas you know we got a new
tradition around here we're gonna dress
more up as Santa Claus
okay here we go and judge yours turned
out perfectly now we're going to fill it
with
buttercream right squeeze and then I'll
move it up all right perfect
oh yeah see that oh I gotta smooth it
move smooth it out I'm glad this isn't a
race
yeah you guys are flying over there you
want some of theirs hey
no cheating what I do is this actually
I'll show you oh I know what you're
gonna do no you do it I won't do this so
this is
Oh I thought you were gonna slap yeah
Dad we are gonna need your help with
sprinkles
yeah so show kind of show Dina
the cake over this yeah there's a lot of
confidence judge okay
you gotta do this on top right no well
we can we can who cares it's ours here
we go
you're cleaning up bud I'm not cleaning
up I'm telling you right now
did he just put your stuff right on top
I don't even need the porters great okay
look this is coming out the top
how about I put five one two yeah put
one for each one for each one of them
well I'll do seven because then four
five
six well let's say it's the five but you
got seven seven five Specialty Cake mine
is so bad be careful I wasn't supposed
to put the sprinkles on top guys
[Music]
this will be our new Christmas tradition
coming and doing fun things like this
together good to be with you to all of
you at home Merry Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas
okay can I eat a cookie
the fives Bakers here now we got cake
and cookies from Carlos's Bakery right
here on the table judge and Danny you
want to lead us I would just say it's a
really Incredible family business they
have such an amazing beautiful products
they work so well together they have
very loyal staff they've been around for
a long time highly recommend them I'm a
I I was obviously terrible at it the
judge she was the best well first of all
what I like about them I like the fact
that uh the staff there people who work
there seem very happy a lot of people
have been there for many years and I was
able to eat my way through the place
from the start to the finish and my
family in Wyoming they got a big
shipment from them as a Merry Christmas
and said everything was absolutely
delicious
well that's great it looks pretty good
so it's very good who made this one was
it you I think that's a freshman cookies
are incredible hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else